so welcome George to the GSB and thanks
for coming we're happy to have you um
I'm gonna start by taking us back to the
70s it's a little bit of a theme around
here today looks like a good theme in
1976 you and your cousin Henry Kravis
decided to leave your cushy banking jobs
at Bear Sterns
and start a new firm in an industry that
didn't even really exist so what were
you thinking well it seemed like a good
idea at the time
know the facts of people borrowing money
to buy companies this not new and
original in fact one of the largest
buyouts specially if you projected out
today's value was the the biota and the
merger of that created us deal with JP
Morgan did back and I think it's 1906
and that track transaction back there
was I think about a billion won in value
which was quite frank there was 7% of
the total US P&P at the time and it was
financed with some gold backed bonds
some convertible securities JP Morgan
and his buddies all bought some penny
stock and then they sold it to the
market of dollars and that's where the
term watered stock came in because
that's what they did and eventually
there were laws against it so what
what we were doing was not new the new
part of it was really making management
partners in what we did and while I was
at Bear Sterns quite frankly when I was
in law school I worked and we had done
probably 12 or 15 management buyouts at
Bear Sterns the firm at the time really
did one-up invest capital in that area
so Henry Jerry and I borrowed the money
for the equity to do it now the deals
were quite a bit smaller and you know
and at the time very very difficult to
put together finally we had built up
enough credibility with some banks some
insurance companies and some wealthy
families that in 1975 we were able to
buy a collection of nine businesses from
Rockwell and we paid 105 million dollars
for it we were able to get that
transaction done it took about a year to
do it we called everybody that we knew
to which and we needed everybody we knew
to put up the money to do it and that
really convinced us that you know hey we
could do this on our own so we didn't
just wake up one day and say hey this is
a good idea let's go do it
we had the training the experience we
had some experience of some deals not
working out quite frankly you learn more
from those than we do your successes and
we you know had a reputation of fair
dealing and integrity that we had
established with some key financial
institutions in order to do it and then
the final thing is in 1974 in 1975 the
US had gone through a tough economic
period of time it was really after the
oil shocks and the oil embargo of 1973
wage price controls were put on at some
point time so we were we felt we were
coming out of a recession and to
a reasonable period of time and it just
seemed like you know seemed like a good
thing to do
Bear Stearns was going this way they
were they were growing they wanted to do
more agency business they really didn't
like investing in businesses it took
five seven ten years to mature and to
develop on something I could understand
that Bear Stearns at the time by the way
had 30 million dollars in capital 1976
just as a point of reference Morgan
Stanley had eight million and Goldman
Sachs had thirty so you can see in the
last 32 years how the world has
certainly changed so that's that's what
we did what we did what concerns or
fears did you have at the time about
taking that step oh well that we
wouldn't be successful and I have to go
I had wife and three kids that we'd have
to go live with my mother-in-law but all
kidding aside the and you all here are
privileged to to get the kind of
education that you're getting here and
obviously they have the education you
did before you came here
so I remember specifically saying to
myself you know what's my downside if
this doesn't work and I always came back
to the fact look I had a good education
I have a good education and whatever
we're going to do we really keep my
reputation and our Tegrity and spin
shape and you'll find as you go out in
the world of you many of you already
know this that the system we have in
this country does not penalize failures
as long as you fail honorably the system
will give you a second and a third and a
fourth chance if you're an entrepreneur
and you take some risk as long as you do
it in the right way and that truly was
what I figured that was my downside and
I also knew that if I didn't do this I
would always look back and say you know
I miss
opportunity and and I had a very very
very very supportive wife talk a little
bit about your partnership with Henry
how's that worked and how is it
influenced the leadership or culture at
KKR
and what advice would you give to a GSB
student today thinking about picking a
potential business partner well Henry
and I are first cousins our families
were close growing up I think the last
argument we had was we were about nine
years old and I wanted to ride Henry's
new bike and he didn't want me to so I
shoved you through a window
every ever since then we decided we
better get along we also had two older
siblings and we figured that if we stuck
together we could come back whatever bad
things our older students we're going to
do to us
so as a unique relationship you know I
don't know how many there are like this
in life more or less business my father
told me a long time ago if you could
really go through life and find one
really really good friend and by that I
mean somebody who's got your back and
who's much interested and your welfare
and be and as as he is in his own you
know you're a very lucky person and you
know things just sort of come naturally
I think that we've got a different style
of how we do things but our sense of
values and what we want to accomplish I
think are pretty symbiotic and you know
I don't know what to advice to give you
all in terms of finding the ideal
partner but you need to make sure that
one you can trust them and two that you
share the same value system and that's
don't mean that about making money I
mean the same value systems about what's
important to you in life and you know
what you are is the person I think
that's that's essential to be able to do
that that sounds like anyway so let's
talk a little bit about management
you've had the unique opportunity to see
how lots of different businesses are
managed and I know you've come across a
lot of under managed businesses
throughout your career based on your
experience what are a few common
mistakes that you see managers making or
pitfalls that they run into well so many
times especially in larger companies
people get consumed with the idea of
managing a corporation as opposed to
achieving objectives anytime you have
more than
eight people in a meeting and it lasts
more than an hour it's not going to be
very productive anytime you have three
or four people of meetings in the last
more than two hours it's probably not
going to be very productive and so much
business today is done by you know
meetings and studies and all the stuff
that goes on politics that goes on in
big companies that you really don't pay
attention to what you should be paying
attention on which is to make the
organization that you're responsible for
run better obviously the bigger of the
companies are the more you have to
delegate and rely on other people to
achieve those results and you know I
think Peter Drucker said it pretty well
words I live by and that is you know the
goal of I would use the term leaders not
management is to create an organization
where people can do their best work and
be helped when they need to help and not
be interfered with when they don't so
basically if you if you give people
responsibility which we do and and
rewards for that by making them owners
of the businesses there above them and
you hold them accountable and it's much
of a non-political way as you can you
know you'll get the best you can out of
the organization many times people don't
think like owners I'll give you one
quick example back in the early 80s we
bought up a company called Union Texas
Petroleum which was at the time the
largest independent oil and gas company
in the US we did it jointly with a line
signal they owned half we owned half we
gave 10% basically in options to the
management and back in the 80s that
period of time oil went to $30 a barrel
which was way over the projections that
we had used
and we were making money hand over foot
and then six months later it went to
eight and we were losing a lot of money
and I remember going to a board meeting
we were gonna describe discuss the
budget and the company had spent six
hundred million dollars the year before
and they came in with the budget the
same number I said well this doesn't
make any sense you know oil prices are
down why don't we have to spend the same
money
they went through you know whole litany
of reasons I mean that you really
couldn't you really couldn't fathom so
basically I said look if you as a
management are willing to invest 60
million dollars in this new budget you
know what we'll prove it they said well
we don't have it I suggest you do you
own 10% of the company six hundred
million dollar budget 10% 660 millions
your own money and the light went on you
know and they they came back with a
budget substantially lower they found
the same amount of oil I think a lot of
that human nature I mean to get people
to think like owners or something as
opposed to renters you know if you own a
house you take better care of it than
when you're in it it's not real
complicated and you'd be surprised
what's out there in the corporate world
where people don't know certainly think
the same way speaking of mistakes what's
the big mistake that you've made and
what did you learn from it oh well we
don't have enough time here you know in
terms of just what you know in terms of
mistakes but I don't know I mean you
obviously make mistakes about business
judgment you know whether or not you
should have made the investment or not I
mean that's that's life that you're
gonna you're gonna be in the real word
you're gonna make mistakes even with the
best information I'd say probably the
biggest recurring mistake that we have a
tendency to make is when we and this was
some business now
is when our gut tells us that the
management's really not doing the job
they ought to be doing there's a
tendency to give them a second or third
chance before you make some changes and
I think we've learned over time that if
it's not going to work you're much
better off going in very quickly and
making changes up front organizations
when there's a change of control expect
excuse me
expect change you know you should go do
that and do it do it very very quickly
so we're business standpoint I think
that's you know certainly one you know
you could probably again with hindsight
question whether or not we should have
bought our J or not so much because of
how the economic returns work because
actually with all we went through that
wasn't so bad but really what it did in
terms of turning the spotlight on our
firm from 1988 till this morning or
whatever whatever it is that really
wasn't a very pleasant thing to do it
wasn't a pleasant thing to have to go to
Washington to defend yourself before
some of the brighter lights that we have
in our Congress
you know I guess with hindsight you know
certainly wouldn't have done it again
not because of the the dollars and cents
but because of everything else that went
with it I think it distracted our firm
for a long period of time I know it did
because we we faced an awful lot of
issues that we had to do including
resetting a bunch of bonds and if we had
to reset them there been a number of
banks that would have gone bankrupt and
you know it's somewhat Asia vu all over
again here
so it was a huge responsibility to have
undertaken that when we exited the
company and they were investment great
again and a lot of the issues that we
fought through had been accomplished but
you know I prefer not to have that
experience together you talked about
changing out management and you've
probably hired and fired a lot of CEOs
and managers throughout your career are
there any particular CEOs or leaders
that you found especially inspiring or
effective and what was it about them
that made them stand out well the first
I don't know if inspired or not but the
first company we bought when we left
Bear Stearns was coming to called AJ in
the streets and which was y'all alaska's
you know gold mining company which is a
second large second oldest company on
the New York Stock Exchange and it had
transformed when our group had been a
big shareholder and it at a huge history
but it was no longer really a gold
mining company they've become a
conglomerate and they had aerospace
business militaries business and
automotive business eighty-three
lawsuits a land business and a lot of
other stuff and Ray O'Keefe who was the
CEO that was brought into it was really
a unique individual
I mean I think he had no balance in his
life but he basically worked 18 hours a
day and he got this sorted out and at
the end of period of time we had no
lawsuits or had gotten rid of 30
some-odd money-losing divisions we
basically had four left and you know we
were heading into a recession back in
the back in the 80s early 80s which by
the way you know Dwarfs anything that
you're reading about in the newspapers
1980 1981 in the u.s. we had more people
unemployed than we had during the Great
Depression we had a prime rate of 21%
we had a long vine of 14% so things were
tough then and there's ray with four
businesses right in the teeth of all
this bad stuff going on and he had a
little saying on his desk again
basically I've never forgotten there
basically says you know when the wind
don't blow row
that's what he did and you know the
outcome was financially fantastic for
all of us first transaction we did and
it was nice to get off to a good start
there so you know I think you know what
I can give you lots of other examples
but basically people that lead by
example that don't ask people to do
things they wouldn't willing to do
themselves I mean you know there's rave
in the office and the factories talking
to customers you know a guy that was
doing it so how could you if you work
for him how could you not want to do
that - I'd say that would be a plate a
good example
well you mentioned it so let's talk
about balance um I worked a lot of hours
when I was at KKR having these memories
of sleeping in the office on more than
one occasion given that how do you think
about work-life balance especially in an
industry as demanding as private equity
well you know having used working hard
and sleeping at the office you know
makes my life
you know and if you're not going to do
it now what are you gonna ever do it but
putting it seriously look I think that
I've been blessed in life because I
found something in a very early age that
I love to do I mean a very passionate
about you know the work very passionate
about the firm certainly one of the
fathers of it I take a lot of pride in
what we do and I think when you you know
and I say blessed because I wish that
for all of you did you find something in
your life regardless of what it is that
that you love to do and if you do that
then even going through difficult times
which you will will become easier
because you'll look at these as
challenges in ways that you know you're
going to get over this and your wages
are going to make you stronger if you
have something that you're really
passionate about so I start with that
I've always had a tribute is to my
mother a very strong sense of what's
important in life which is obviously
your family and your family's help and I
focused on my in my life really on my
family and my work which in both cases
were passions of what I love to do so
it's come pretty easy for me with
respect to that I mean you know I've
said this before you know I was married
for almost 36 years before my wife died
I've worked since I was 20 years old
doing what I'm doing now and it was
never a day that I didn't want to go to
work no matter what was life was like
and there was never a day I didn't want
to go home
so again I think you know find the right
mate
in your life somebody that shares the
same values that you do and find
something that you love to do and you'll
you'll work out
the you know the balance so I think this
mean we our last question and it's about
some career advice for all of us
you know I'm trying to find a job right
now and I know that I would benefit and
probably my classmates would for some
advice about what we should be thinking
about when we're deciding where and how
to start our careers well first of all I
have confidence in yourself said earlier
you know you've got what 99% of the
people in the world don't have and
that's a good education and believe me
this will come back to serve you you
know many many times over and in your
life and lots of ways that you don't
expect this will will be there secondly
you know you don't have to make you're
not Japan like Billy was for a while you
know you don't have to make a career
decision for the next 50 years of your
life it's okay to go out and have a
bunch of different jobs and doing what
you're doing so again I would just go
back to something where you don't
overthink it you go find a job that you
really feel that you could contribute in
and you can learn from sort of as a
starter job out of Business School and
see where that takes you and you know
you'll meet lots of people along the way
doors will open for you along the ways
the experience you gain in one set of
jobs will help you in something else
that you're going to do you know work
hard and work with integrity all the
time and opportunities will you know
will be there plenty for you but for the
best of ice I give you is don't don't
stress out too much about it and don't
try to overthink it and if you need to
change jobs in two or three years you
know you haven't come into the sense
well I think that's enough for me we'll
turn it over to questions from the
audience but thanks again for your
candor and for your time and being here
[Applause]
all right it'll work okay so mr. Roberts
it's a privilege to see you here today
but with us the father of KKR and the
father of an industry that many of us
come from and I returning to you'll be
pleased to know that something like four
tenths of the people in this in this
business school belong to the private
equity Club so you've inspired a
generation of people to go and invest in
the short term given the climate where
would you put your money and in the long
term as you look through the fogginess
of the madness right now where do you
see private equity going and KKR within
that well you know I'm not a registered
investment advisor so in terms of where
you would invest today you know I would
really look at the debt markets I mean
they're the ones that are the most most
extreme you know usually what's the
baseball term if you want to get a hit
hit where they ain't so everybody's
running away from things you know you
basically have had government agencies
traded 300 over Treasuries you know
you've got fear and panic in the credit
markets today so that's what I would go
do probably the second area I would look
at would be to go buy some mortgages or
some homes from some banks in areas that
you think at some point time will cover
and people won't want to live it I think
you'll do really well there in terms of
the environment today people lose sight
of what's really our business our
business is really making investments at
companies and making it better so that's
what our job has to be most people focus
on well can you do deals sherry Kathy
you know they'll be you can do them
today you know if you want to pay the
pay the cost of capital we'll do it you
know the markets aren't totally shut
we've done
two deals one in Turkey and one in the
UK in the last six months so if for us
what we need to do is continue to focus
on making the investments that we have
better if we do that we'll be able to
continue to attract capital and by that
I mean not just financial capital in
human capital and we'll be able to grow
our business around the world where
we're we're basically set up today so
it's keeping your head down keeping
focused on what's important today like
yesterday and the year before the most
important thing we have is our
investment that's where we have our
money that's where the people that have
trusted us have their money we've got to
make that work do you make that work
lots of other good things happen and you
can grow grow your business but you know
the this form of investment whether you
call a private equity or buyouts or
whatever it is is not going away every
every ten or fifteen years and the Dean
knows this better than I do
thanks figure out a new way to lose
money not that they don't have enough
existing ways but they figure out new
ways and we'll go through this period
the banks will deleverage the balance
sheets there's going to be a lot of
losses it's gonna be a lot of angst with
this to be a lot of layoffs of financial
institutions and then they'll wake up
one day and say well you know we got to
make money again and they make money by
lending forever so life will go on
you hear me okay you mentioned that you
know you mentioned the 81 recession and
you don't throughout your career I think
you've been through through several
cycles and how do you see the current
situation you know probably heading into
a significant recession and how do you
see your companies being placed but
we've weathered the storm
could you give me the last part again
please basically how do you see the
portfolio companies you're currently
like you know owning weather to the
storm and you know which kind of plans
do you have or you know you see a
massive challenge or not as I understand
it the question is how do we see KKR
whether in their store and whatever
plans a portfolio companies okay well we
have we have 44 investments today if you
aggregated them sales or 185 billion
dollars and they they employ eight
hundred and eighty thousand people so we
have a huge responsibility to all the
constituencies that are involved in that
and from the day that before we make an
investment we try to figure out what
we're gonna do to make that business
better and we spend a lot of time in our
decision-making process
that's why Selena sleeps on the couch
when she worked for us and trying to
figure out you know what are we going to
do you know when the dog catches the bus
and then we have some very good
processes in place to make sure that
what we said we were going to do is
going to get done we have an Operations
Group within KKR that gets into all the
details of the business in terms of how
they can be improved many of the
investments we've made we actually had
our team in in the end and working in a
company prior to actually owning it so
the focus from day one from the time you
say well this is a good idea do you
actually make the investment you have to
live and breathe operational improvement
in those
so it has to be engraved in the culture
of the people that work at KKR and
everybody that's there to help you
that's not to say you don't make
mistakes or their macro things that work
today in the world which they obviously
are that are making that difficult but
you have to stay after it every day and
you have to follow up you have to hold
your people accountable for doing what
they say and you have to be all over
there has been a lot of emerging market
fundraising activity recently given the
environment given the financial markets
the way they are currently how do you
see this trend panning out particularly
in light of you know flight to safety
kind of argument that a lot of experts
are you know coming out with and you
know where do you see the balance
between chasing the Returns versus
flight to safety what was the last part
again where do you see the balance
between chasing the returns in emerging
markets versus flight to safety okay
well in the emerging markets you know
we're we're sort of there you know in
China we've got investments in China
we've got an investments in India so
we're obviously looking at that
but in terms of where you see values
today quite frankly the stock market has
not come down enough to really reflect
what you would have to pay to to buy
something so we're sitting there on in a
very nice position with an awful lot of
capital and in terms of in times of
turmoil that we're in it's great to be
liquid it's great to have capital in
this period of time I have no doubt that
we'll be able to find some productive
places to put this I can't tell you what
month or when
what it's gonna be but we've been doing
this long enough to know that there are
cycles that take place I've seen this
happened five times now and in my career
and you know the the Black Swan always
shows up sometime and it always shows up
differently than you would think and
then it goes away differently than your
thing
these are periods of time where there'll
be different kinds of opportunities than
going out and buying a hundred percent
of the business it could be taking a
minority stake which we did and Lake
Mason in the business it could be you
know creating a pool of capital to go by
debt which we've done so you need to you
know to be able to go with the flow to
so to speak and look and see where the
opportunities are when you have
situations like this but you guys will
look back in three or four years now and
you'll be this period of time it's a
great opportunity to have made some
money if you picked the right bet
good you you know you spoke briefly
about the RJR do and how maybe that had
brought a little more attention to the
industry than you would have liked I
mean again you're still seeing maybe
expensive birthday parties and other
things bringing a little more attention
than you may like to the the industry
what what do you think has gone wrong
and what can private equity do to show
that they really are a net creator of
jobs and not just a bunch of Liquidators
essentially okay well all you got to do
is to see what our records are is to
look at them they're their eyes have
been audited the informations there so
you know the but that's not interesting
for the press to write about okay and
look really what's happened is and it's
not just private equity but there's been
a lot of money made in the last ten
years in the United States and you can
individualize that you don't see this
Warren Buffett get the same you know
criticism that Stephen Schwarzman kids
but you know if people want to go pick
pick Warren apart I mean believe me they
can find a lot of wards but you don't
see that you know so when you can when
the press can individualize this they do
it I mean it happened with Mike Milken
this is back in the 80s Mike Milken made
five hundred million dollars one year
you know if he had been in a corporation
and the stock had gone up he'd stopped
taking stocks out of cash nobody would
run it so don't forget that the press
needs to sell newspapers they need to
get sound bites they need to do this and
it's uh you know there's not a lot of
people that you know are too sympathetic
to us
you've got union activism here with
respect to it that have their own of
goals and objectives so you've got all
these forces and we've seen it I've seen
it happen now
time's certainly happened in the RJR
Deal days I can remember going down and
having breakfast with the whole House
Ways Means Committee this was a day
after the savings alone bill got passed
that bailed out all the S&L so I figured
nobody's gonna be down there to you know
listen to what we have to say but they
all showed up and I can remember one
particular senator who's still a senator
sitting next to me he said you know I
don't care what you say you're never
gonna convince me I so I said well why
why are you here and he said well and
that at the time Henry was married
married to a lady that designed clothes
said my wife told me to come so that I
could talk to mr. Kravis about his
wife's latest designs like Henry knew a
lot you know about so I mean you know
you're always going to have this you
have a you know a populist movement now
in the in the in the Congress and you
know it's as hard as it is to read about
stuff that's not right
you eventually get a bit you know you
get a thicker skin and you just gotta
let it roll off of you and there's some
people that you know in the middle of
the fire flight stick to pop their head
up and say or do some stupid things that
add just to the a dullness
I noticed that you're carrying the book
leadership secrets of Attila the Hun and
I don't think that's in the core
curriculum right now so I'm just curious
what your what what selections you found
most interesting and and would want to
convey to students well I'm glad glad
yeah now many of you don't know much
about a Atilla the Hun nor should you
but he was a unique character he was
born in 400 AD there abouts he was the
son of a king of the Huns
he basically United a nomadic group of
people which now is Eastern Europe and
he was a tough guy but and again I don't
know whether he wrote some of the things
in the air but there's some particular
sayings that he had I think that pertain
to leadership which I thought maybe
maybe I just shared with you a little
bit above all traits one who desires to
lead must possess an intrinsic desire to
achieve substantial personal recognition
and be willing to earn it at all
fairness you must have resilience to
overcome personal misfortune
discouragement rejection and
disappointment you must have the courage
creativity and stamina to focus on
accomplishing your responsibilities
through the directed delegated efforts
of subordinates you must recognize and
accept that your greatness will be made
possible through the extremes of your
personality the very extremes that
sometimes make the campfire satyrs
and legendary stories you must remember
that success in your office will depend
largely upon your sustained willingness
to work hard sweat rules over
inspiration you must be committed to
preserve even in the face of opposition
and challenge you must have a passion
to succeed a passion that drives you to
prepare yourself in your hands to excel
you must be willing to remain your
natural self not take on an Aurora of
false pride in your countenance so
Attila had some pretty cool things to
say that I think applied you know - you
know everyone's everyday life and every
once in a while I'd pick it up and read
it always find something a little bit
different you know say about it now he
died you know he had many many wives
that I think his left last wife poisoned
him because he had killed her father so
don't do everything that
well in terms of succession planning you
know we think about it all the time but
you know voluntarily you have no plans
to leave you know in the foreseeable
future but part of your job if you're
gonna be a leader an organization is to
make sure that you have a good
succession plan and my hopes are that
the people that take over after Henry
and I aren't there do a better job than
we've done I mean I I want to make sure
that we have the quality of the people
in the firm with those skills that can
do that in terms of how we share the
economics to the firm I think this has
sort of been unique to KKR everybody
it's a full-time employee in the firm as
an ownership and everything we do so
when you go to our office a lady to
greet you at the door is an owner and
everything that we do we've shared the
ownership deeply throughout the firm
everybody participates regardless of
whether they're involved in a situation
or not basically the folks that we have
in China or Japan or Australia or Europe
or the u.s. we all participate equally
and everything that gets gets done
throughout the firm so when you when you
take that out of the organization and
without people having to fight every
year over what they think they should be
reasonably paid you create an
environment that where people
communicate a little bit better and
you've taken a lot of the politics out
of it so if you take that and you make
sure that you communicate with people
two or three times a year and if they're
they have some issues and ways that they
need to improve maybe even more so so
you get people feedback you know you'll
get the best out of your people
you know we've I think we probably have
lost nine nine people since we started
KKR only one really went into the buyout
business and he's I don't know what he's
doing now you know people tend to want
to stand and stay and make a career and
what we do some people have wanted to do
other things
ned's got left to start up you know a
small hedge fund basically we've had
guys late leave to go start nonprofits
so and most importantly we've we've had
a thousand when we go out and try to
hire people so we must must be doing
something right so again I think if you
keep it simple you treat people fairly
and communicate with them and you take
uncertainty out of their lives you know
provided they perform you'll get the
best out of everyone
so you've obviously created this entity
which has been hugely successful been
very good at doing that
it's wondering how do you how do you
think about spending so the rest of your
time what is the or vision for the rest
of your life it's like what do you do
besides work oh well I try to stay fit
[Music]
you know I start around 5:30 in the
morning and go do that for about an hour
I work I like to practice my golf I have
four grandchildren and another one on
the way I like to they all thank
goodness all my children live in the
area so I like to spend time with them I
like like to read enjoy my friends I
know you're involved in the he started
read F venture philanthropy firm and
would love to hear a little bit about
your vision for venture philanthropy and
whether that'll be the wave of the
future in the nonprofit industry
well we my wife and I started when we
were fortunate enough to have the
wherewithal to give back one of the
things we wanted to do was to do
something if we didn't do it wouldn't
get that you know big institutions are
gonna raise money whether you helped
them or not
quite frankly so we look for something
to do and and we basically focused on
something that was not a success but the
first thing we focused on was trying to
create jobs for homelessness and we
narrowed down on women with children the
homeless homeless women with kids as a
group that we thought we should we
should really focus on and we tried to
do that through jobs or jobs training in
many cases helping them create a
business and you know that was not
successful
you know there are lots of reasons for
it but many cases the women that were
homeless were such because it came from
abuse relationships and that there was a
number of times they would keep going
back in that same environment before
they finally got out of it so we we
weren't successful there so then we
spent six months and with a guy named
Chet Emerson and said okay what what is
it that the you know we've got some
skills with they could apply to creating
jobs for people that have either been in
jail or the lowest one percent of the
unemployed group in the Bay Area and
when we found there were probably ten or
twelve really good organizations within
the Bay Area rubicon ventures human
ventures you go through the list that
actually employed folks that that you
know we're at that that level in society
so we said well why don't we create a
venture business where we can take some
money and some expertise of people and
we can help those businesses grow and if
they can grow they can provide more jobs
and training for people and so that we
did we started financing about eight of
those and we built up a staff Jed who
was probably the most left-wing social
worker in the whole world actually went
back to business school Santa Clara and
he's become a real capitalist now so he
figured if he was going to do this he
better learn something about it he did
and we built up a team to basically go
in and help organizations to do this and
then we said well how do we know that
what we're really spending is making a
difference
are we really spending our money wisely
because funds aren't unlimited and we
developed a metric system and tracking
system of what to do there and you know
we found by all measurements that many
of these organizations were you know
doing good things for people that had a
reduced financial cost than if they did
I mean you compare it to going back to
jail you compare it to drug situations
compared to where the wages were could
they afford to actually rent an
apartment they did they stay out of
trouble and so we tried to develop the
Metra C's for that and I think that's
really the you know probably the heart
of what's come out of all this so today
we jed's moved on we have a lady named
Karla Javits who runs that we also said
well you know we can't just keep
supporting the same organizations over
and over again because they need to
stand on their own so let's go find some
other groups that we can help which
Carla's done and the goal is over the
next two years is to create another
three thousand you know jobs for people
that wouldn't have them whether we can
do that I don't know but the whole
purpose is really to take a very
underserved population of people and be
able to get them in some more permanent
employment and a lot of the groups they
go through whether it be Rubicon or Yuma
whatever it is they're really just
training grounds for people within to go
out and get you know get a different job
so that was the theory behind it I think
it's 12 years now that we've been going
at it we've expanded the board and we've
gotten the other thing I said is you
know if what we're doing is so wonderful
then we ought to stand the market test
and let's go out to the not-for-profit
world and see if we can raise money from
out other people that really believe in
what we're doing and Hewlett Foundation
has been very helpful with that as
Rockefeller and others so you know it's
it's just this slice of what we're
trying to do and we're trying to keep it
local I don't think there's a you can
manage an organization like that and you
know nationally but you know it's
amazing what you can do with just put
some time and effort well unfortunately
George I think we're out of time now but
I just wanted to thank you again for
coming and for sharing all of your
insights and experiences and hopefully
we'll see you back at the GSB again soon
thank you